Italy now has the largest coronavirus
death toll outside China
authorities there announced 49 more
deaths on Friday bringing the overall
toll - just shy of 200 as the economic
impact starts to sink in the Italian
tourism industry is already predicting
losses of 8 billion dollars Charlie
d'Agata is in Rome this morning Charlie
good morning
well good morning from the Vatican which
is just announced its first case the big
question now is what kind of impact is
that going to have in the run-up to Holy
Week and Easter next month with cases
across Italy surging again now at more
than 4600 nearly 200 dead it was only a
matter of time before the virus
penetrated the Vatican walls - in
extreme measures to face the spread
head-on Italy ordered a nationwide
shutdown of schools and universities
American students studying abroad had
already got the call to pull out like
Eric Meade from Montgomery County
Maryland if I want to stay like I should
be able to stay and we're up to you
you'd be like no way I'm staying oh yeah
definitely definitely like I want to
stay and I don't think that it's
necessary for me to go home the vast
majority of victims are among the
elderly and Italy's got the oldest
population in Europe the government has
urged older citizens to stay indoors and
as this crisis deepens Italy now faces a
new normal and an uncertain future
American University President Richard
Hodges when you first got an idea of
what was going on what went through your
mind I could threaten the future of the
university that that dramatic yes
because who knows how long this will go
on for students we spoke to are less
worried of falling ill with the virus
than being stuck here or infecting
family members back home and I think
like like it's just like it's spreading
everywhere like I don't think like
America is gonna be like a special case
where just like magically like doesn't
spread now we're told students will
finish their coursework online by the
way they said they were fine being
treated by the Italian healthcare system
it's not only very good it's free
Michele how about that Charlie d'Agata
in Rome thank you